pourquoi dit-on il y as anguille sous
roche c'est une question de passion
nature pêche si j'en crois votre pseudo
cher passion nature pêche vous serez
ravis d'apprendre que cette expression
qui remonte au 16e siècle nous vient des
pêcheurs ce poisson vit surtout la nuit
et n'aime pas trop la lumière pendant la
journée il cherche donc à se cacher
c'est pourquoi il était très courant
autrefois de tomber sur une anguille
lorsqu'on soulever une pierre sous l'eau
une anguille cacher d'autres on ne
soupçonnait pas la présence mais
l'expression pourrait aussi être liée au
verbe guillet de l'ancien français qui
signifie tromper si on ajoute à cela la
ressemblance avec le serpent animal à la
mauvaise réputation
l'anguille devient alors un animal
fourbe symbole de tromperie voilà
pourquoi l'expression il y as anguille
sous roche signifie non seulement que
tout n'est pas clair que quelque chose
ait caché mais sous entend aussi
généralement qu'un sale coup est en
préparation